[MUSIC PLAYING]
[ALARM RINGING]
[GRUNTS]
Aw, I hate when I do that.
Keep an eye on me, Gambit.
You might learn something.
This is your first
Christmas as an X-Man, and we
need to make it extra special.
It already is.
Observe.
First, we charge the cue.
Maybe Monsieur Gambit's not
as good as he thinks he is.
I must first find my sister
and maybe see more of America
after I fix your house.
I never realized how
much this dump meant to me
till somebody wiped it out.
[ALARM SOUNDING]
It will take time to put right
what Sinister tried to destroy.
Thankfully, the X-Men have
proved what I'd always hoped,
that in my absence they
can carry on together
with our important work.
After what we've
been through lately,
I figured we could
use some time off.
What the heck?
Destroy all mutants?
With the friends of
humanity, who needs enemies?
Where's that blasted salami?
I can smell it.
Ah, all it needs is slicing.
While you're at
it, fix one for me.